[Music]
many people would like to think that
racism is a thing of the past but I'm
here to tell you that racism is
institutionalized and very much a part
of our systems today prior to business
school I spent a lot of my spare time
advising small businesses and during
that time I saw time and time again that
there could be two businesses with
virtually the same exact profile on
paper but experience totally different
outcomes when the only thing that
separated the two was the color of their
owners skin every time I go back home to
my hometown of Baltimore Maryland
I'm known as the business guy I mean
I've done taxes for Mobile retailers
marketing plans for bus companies I've
read tons and tons of business plans
I've even managed property all while
working full-time in Washington DC as a
regulatory compliance and cybersecurity
consultant but one day I got a call from
the daycare center that I went to while
growing up in Baltimore asking for my
help with their small business loan
application I mean I went to this Center
my brother went there my mother had
worked there in over 22 years the center
had touched the lives of thousands of
people within our community and had a
huge impact on my family so on when I
went to visit them I saw that they had
46 children currently enrolled in the
program eight full-time employees and a
long long wait list of families just
hoping to enroll in the program I
noticed that on paper this was a solid
business opportunity with 22 years of
track record of positive cash flows and
also profitability
so I prepared their business plan in
their application and I went to a bank
and after a few meetings our loan
application was denied
we move forward and we went to a second
bank but after a few meetings again our
loan application was denied so I asked a
few questions and we revisited and
revised our materials and we presented
an even stronger case and we went to a
third bank and again our loan
application was denied so I felt
confused I felt helpless why couldn't
the bank's acknowledge the value that
was clearly on the paper a solid
business opportunity according to a
Baltimore Economic Development Group
black entrepreneurs are denied small
business loans up to three times more
often than white entrepreneurs so I
asked myself a question why can't black
people get loans in Baltimore and so I
googled it
and I spent some time scrolling through
the results and after a few minutes I
saw Matt and honestly I'll never forget
the Matt so if I step back in time and
tell you about the 1930s during that
time the government had amazing ideas
like the 30-year fixed interest rate
mortgage
the government also created the
homeowners Loan Corporation the holc
which was designed to evaluate 239
cities across the country and literally
draw lines on maps categorizing them
green blue yellow and red green meant
the rich upper income white people areas
blue meant middle-class white people
yellow met poor white people and then
black said that wrong
red red was labeled hazardous on the mat
in red meant black did we see the
difference here the government literally
created a system where they categorized
white people by socioeconomic class he
then created a separate catch-all bucket
of its own for black people and marked
it hazardous red line maps like this old
map from the 1930s in Baltimore
institutionalized racism in my hometown
in this study as recent as 2017 found
that 74% 74 percent of areas that were
marked red back in nineteen in the 1930s
are today still low and moderate-income
and almost entirely majority black today
while 91% 91 percent of areas that were
marked green over 80 years ago our upper
income in majority white today
so redlining like this has really had an
impact on so many communities and
frankly it makes a mockery of our ideals
of the American Dream in this country in
1977 the government created the
Community Reinvestment Act which is a
law that federally mandated banks to
devote a portion of its loan portfolio
investments in services to the low and
moderate income communities in which
they were operating in but too many
neighborhoods too many people and too
many businesses are just not seeing
those loans investments or services this
come travel to Maryland with me and you
can see it for yourself it's going on
right in front of our eyes and we are
not doing anything to make change happen
the Community Reinvestment Act was meant
to end redlining
but racism has been institutionalized in
our healthcare systems education systems
banking housing in criminal justice
systems and frankly it makes a mockery
of our ideals of the American Dream
there are billions in billions of
dollars of high-quality investment
opportunities that are still being left
on the table black Americans have 1.2
trillion dollars of buying power an
incredibly innovative ideas for products
and businesses that just need better
that deserve better
but we continue we continue to leave
those high-quality opportunities on the
table
we haven't erased the red lines of the
past we just continue to limit our
country's full economic potential is
this the type of country we want to live
in to raise our families in to leave for
really is it okay that your zip code is
a better predictor of your health
outcomes than your genetic code really
is it okay that three out of four
neighborhoods that were marked red over
80 years ago are the majority of our low
and moderate-income communities today
really is it okay that even on this very
past weekend in 2019 a very nice woman
still asked me what is it like to be a
black man in business because it must be
really really hard and you know what
she's right it's hard because
collectively we haven't been questioning
our ideals and perspectives on race
class in the American dream collectively
we haven't been questioning our local
banks and asking them what are they
doing to provide loans investments and
services and to the low-income
communities in which they are operating
in but today you can help and right now
we can all make a difference I recently
launched a website called grant bridges
org where you can go and you can
nominate a business that may be
underserved so we can better connect
them with their local banks in their
community today you can change the
paradigm and shift the way that we think
about risk and move away from these
old-school racially charged color-coded
systems because collectively we need
better collectively we all deserve
better there are billions in billions of
dollars of high-quality value that's
being left on the table billions of
dollars of opportunity that just so
happens to be located in black
communities today it's time to redesign
our future for everyone including those
46 children those eight workers in that
long long wait
a family's from my daycare in Baltimore
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]